-Good evening, I'm Seth Meyers
and this is "Late Night."
How's everybody doing tonight?
That's so good to hear.
President Biden was photographed
on Thursday
picking a dandelion from
the White House lawn
and giving it to First Lad
Dr. Jill Biden,
and right about there is whe
Kamala Harris called
for a bible.
Oop! False alarm!
Nope. He's getting back up
Yup. No, just picking a flower
The Kentucky Derby was thi
weekend.
"And they're off!" said
Americans about their TVs.
According to his advisors,
former president Trump
is still challenging the results
of the 2020 election
and has called for a hand
recount of 2 million ballots
cast in Arizona's largest
county, which brings us to
a segment called
"Seth tries to think of
literally anything
more pathetic."
♪♪♪♪
Asking your mom to prom?
No.
Helping the guy your wife ha
an affair move?
No. Asking your mom to pro
and she's already going with
someone else?
No, I can't do it.
-This has been,
"Seth tries to think of
literally anything
more pathetic."
-I cannot believe Scollins
wrote that joke
and then did the voice over.
Is there anyone --
Is there anyone working here o
quality control?
[ Laughs ]
And a real flat read, too.
Let's be honest,
it's not like...
It's not like he's our staff's
Morgan Freeman.
Well, we had to let him do it.
I can't believe he wasn't busy
with other voiceover work.
President Biden said last week
that he was not given
advance notice of the raid o
former president Trump's
personal attorney
Rudy Giuliani's home,
and I would have believed him if
he hadn't had popcorn
all over his suit.
U.S. troops began their
withdrawal last week
from Afghanistan after nearl
20 years occupying the country
To give you an idea of
how long that is...
That's right -- U.S. troop
began their withdrawal
last week from Afghanistan
Biden has plenty of reasons,
but number one is definitely
those YouTube videos where the
surprise a dog.
Aww.
Dang it, gets me every time.
Former president Trump was
reportedly presented with
a 24-page proposal
to launch his own
multi-billion-dollar
media company,
and under his leadership,
in a few years, it could becom
a multi-million-dollar company
After visiting former presiden
Jimmy Carter at his home
on Thursday, President Biden
told reporters
that they, quote, "Sat and
talked about the old days.
Like, when they worked
side-by-side
to try to bring down crime and
gas prices and that mammoth.
According to Politico, 17% o
President Biden's
White House staffers
have degrees from
Harvard University.
Said the other 83%,
"Ugh, we know."
Authorities in Pennsylvani
announced last week
that they arrested a man
after they discovered
$1 million worth of
crystal meth,
6 so-called ghost guns,
and Nazi paraphernalia durin
a raid.
And now the man is trying to
decide if he should
accept a plea deal or just g
ahead and run for Congress
The NYPD recently announced that
it will no longer use
it's controversial so-called
robot dog, and once again,
Travis stepped up to the plate
-He was my dog.
I'll do it.
-Real hot Monday for Scollins.
And finally, the Italian
motorcycle company Benelli
recently launched a new scoote
called the Dong,
and it's a pretty good scooter
except in cold weather.
That...was a monologue,
everybody.